[موسيقى] في
جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة ، تستمر حالات covid19 في
الارتفاع مدفوعة بفروع أوميكرون هذا
المتغير ba-5 شديد العدوى
ويمكن أن يصيب الأشخاص الذين تم
تطعيمهم سابقًا وكذلك الأشخاص الذين لديهم
عهد سابق بينما يشعر الكثيرون
بالقلق من فوز اللقاحات الحالية
يقول مسؤولو الصحة في الولايات المتحدة إنهم سيقللون
بشكل كبير من خطر
الإصابة بأعراض covid19 الحادة ، فنحن
نهتم حقًا
بمنع الأشخاص من الإصابة بالمرض
لدرجة أنهم في نهاية المطاف بحاجة إلى
دخول المستشفى وهذا ما
تفعله فائدة التطعيم والمعززات  تُظهر بيانات cdc
أن ثلثي السكان
قد تم تطعيمهم بالكامل على الأقل
بسلسلتهم الأولية ولكن أقل من الثلث
حصلوا على جرعة معززة إذا كان عمرك
يزيد عن 50 عامًا ولم تحصل على لقطة
هذا العام في عام 2022.  واحد
الآن معظم الناس مؤهلون
للحصول على
جرعة ثالثة من لقاح فايزر أو لقاح covid19 الحديث
بعد خمسة أشهر على الأقل من السلسلة الأولية لمن هم في سن
الخمسين وما فوق  أو أولئك الذين يبلغون من العمر 12 عامًا
والذين يعانون من نقص المناعة مؤهلون أيضًا
للحصول على جرعة معززة ثانية
بعد أربعة أشهر على الأقل من أول
جرعة ، بينما قد تكون اللقاحات التي تستهدف أشكالًا جديدة من متغير omicron قادمًا
يقول مسؤولو الصحة في الولايات المتحدة ، لا تنتظر لحماية
نفسك الآن.  لا يزال مؤهلاً
للحصول على تلك التعزيزات المحددة المتنوعة بمجرد
توفرها في وقت لاحق من الخريف
للدقيقة الصحية ، فأنا ماندي غايثر